allora io vorrei cominciare
con la fantasia di un ragazzo un ragazzo
di 16 anni che appassionato di fisica e
lui si fa ispirare proprio dalle ultime
scoperte nel campo
dell'elettromagnetismo e quindi immagina
di trovarsi a cavallo di un raggio di
luce la luce forse lo saprete
e un'onda elettromagnetica e si domanda
cosa vedrai intorno a sé va veloce come
la luce alla luce viaggia a circa
300.000 chilometri al secondo
sarà in grado di vedere qualcosa oppure
andando alla velocità degli altri raggi
luminosi non riuscire a vedere niente
si pone quindi questa domanda ma il
punto centrale che non è un ragazzo
qualunque perché einstein einstein
racconta questa cosa nella sua
autobiografia scientifica nel 47 dicendo
che proprio in quella fantasia che ebbe
quando aveva 16 anni
c'era già in nuce quello che poi sarebbe
diventata la teoria della relatività
generale
una teoria che non ha sconvolto soltanto
il mondo della fisica ma anche il nostro
modo di intendere noi stessi e il nostro
posto all'interno dell'universo non che
l'universo stesso che ha portato a una
serie di scoperte straordinarie ve ne
indico qualcuna questa probabilmente
l'avrete vista è la cosiddetta prima
immagine di un buco nero anche se
immagine un termine un po in proprio in
questo caso perché è l'insieme di più
immagini ottenute nelle onde radio anche
quelle onde elettromagnetiche è stata
presentata al pubblico ad aprile di
quest'anno è un buco nero
tutto quello che vedete in questa
immagine si comporta esattamente come
stato previsto da einstein nella teoria
della relatività generale del 1916 ma vi
dico di più noi portiamo la relatività
letteralmente in tasca perché
all'interno dei nostri cellulari c'è il
gps che ci permette di usare il
navigatore il gps deve tener presente le
correzioni dovute agli effetti della
relatività generale altrimenti
commetterebbe un errore sulla
determinazione della nostra posizione di
15 km quindi neppure un effetto
trascurabile
questa è la mia preferita in assoluto
che è la prima rivelazione delle onde
gravitazionali previste sempre nel 1916
conseguenza della teoria della
relatività generale
le abbiamo cercate per sessant'anni di
speravamo di poterle mai vedere
questo rivelatore che si chiama laico in
realtà sono due antenne che si trovano
negli stati uniti a settembre del 2015
riesce a captare una di queste illusive
onde gravitazionali la notizia poi verrà
data al pubblico sei mesi dopo a
febbraio del 2016 proprio esattamente
cento anni dopo l'articolo che
presentava la teoria della relatività
generale al pubblico però cerchiamo un
attimo di contestualizzare la fantasia
del giovane einstein nella fisica del
periodo siamo più o meno nella seconda
metà dell'ottocento
lui è james maxwell che è un fisico
scozzese che aveva anche lui
rivoluzionato la fisica del suo tempo
perché aveva unificato nei campi
elettrici campi magnetici in un'unica
teoria che viene espressa da sei
equazioni che portano il suo nome ma
aveva trovato anche una cosa paradossale
per i fisici del suo tempo quella che
vedete espressa da questa formula c è la
velocità della luce appunto circa
300.000 chilometri al secondo poteva
essere espressa come una costante per
che derivava da due costanti quelle che
vedete g10 ex ceylon 0 che rappresentano
semplicemente il modo con cui il vuoto
si comporta nei confronti del campo
magnetico il primo termine quello più a
sinistra del campo elettrico
quello invece più a destra perché era
paradossale perché noi siamo abituati a
trattare le velocità in altri termini
immaginiamo di essere dei ladri che sono
su un treno stanno rubando qualcosa il
treno viaggio a 50 metri al secondo
ci sono dei poliziotti che ci vogliono
fermare uno si trova sul treno con noi
il poliziotto a l'altro invece cerca di
fermarci dalla banchina il poliziotto b
entrambi hanno una pistola che spara
proiettili che vanno a 100 metri al
secondo
allora noi ladro vedremo il proiettile
che proviene dal poliziotto a viaggiare
a 100 metri al secondo il poliziotto è
sul treno con noi invece il proiettile
che viene sparato dal poliziotto b andrà
a un'altra velocità per il ladro il
ladro infatti si sta allontanando dal
poliziotto dalla banchina a 50 metri al
secondo bisognerà sottrarre questa
velocità a quella del proiettile quindi
il ladro vedrà il proiettile andare a 50
metri al secondo
all'interno di tutto ciò che è
abbastanza intuitivo come si inserisce
in fatto di fatto che invece la velocità
della luce è sempre una costante
è una cosa un grosso problema per i
fisici dell'epoca che cercarono di
risolverlo
ad esempio immaginando che le onde
elettromagnetiche si propagassero
all'interno di un mezzo chiamato etere
che rappresentava una specie di sistema
di riferimento fisso al quale tutti gli
altri dovevano riferirsi appunto e il
problema però era trovare delle prove
dell'esistenza di questo etere se
esisteva davvero tutti gli oggetti
dovevano muoversi rispetto a questo
etere quindi ad esempio doveva essere
possibile misurare la velocità della
terra rispetto all'etere questa era
l'idea della l'idea alla base di questo
esperimento fatto due fisici
statunitensi michael sono e morli che
usarono questo apparato che si vede in
questa foto si chiama interferometro
piccola parentesi lo stesso tipo di
apparato verrà utilizzato poi per
rivelare le onde gravitazionali per i
corsi e ricorsi della scienza con questo
strumento volevano misurare la velocità
della terra rispetto all'etere e non ci
riuscirono
il problema dell'etere rimaneva sospeso
non si capiva come era possibile questa
cosa in tutto questo si inserisce
einstein con una considerazione se
vogliamo banale ma geniale lui dice ok
allora la velocità della luce è una
costante
sempre nel nostro esempio del treno che
succede che se immaginiamo di essere nel
futuro per cui i poliziotti a noi faser
come in star trek 15 sparano dei raggi
luminosi noi vedremo entrambi i raggi
sia quello del poliziotto a che è quello
del poliziotto di viaggiare sempre alla
velocità della luce anche se noi siamo
sul treno che sta andando a 50 metri al
secondo
però noi sappiamo un'altra cosa che la
velocità è uguale a spazio diviso tempo
infatti quando andiamo in macchina
misuriamo la velocità in chilometri al
secondo
il km l'intervallo spaziale scusate
allora l'ora e l'intervallo temporale
spazio diviso tempo se la velocità ci
deve essere costante
non lo saranno più nello spazio nel
tempo e questo è un salto veramente
straordinario noi eravamo sempre
abituati a immaginare soprattutto il
tempo come una cornice fissa all'interno
della quale le nostre vicende umane le
vicende dell'universo si dipanavano
adesso invece non è più vero tanto lo
spazio che il tempo dipendono dalla
velocità
ritorniamo sempre nel futuro andiamo con
star trek immaginiamo di avere la nostra
interpres che viaggia a frazioni sempre
maggiore della velocità della luce v
uguale 0.20 significa 20 per cento della
velocità della luce
0 99 e 99 per cento della velocità della
luce più veloci andiamo più per un
osservatore che guarda da fuori l'inter
price cul enterprise tenderà a contrarsi
e questo già un cambiamento filosofico
di grande importanza ma questa è solo la
teoria della relatività ristretta che
vale quindi soltanto per i cosiddetti
sistemi di riferimento inerziali cioè
quelli che sono fermi rispetto
all'osservatore o si muovo nel moto
rettilineo uniforme
quindi nel quale la velocità sempre la
stessa sia nel valore sia nella
direzione per farvi un esempio noi siamo
tutti fissi su un sistema di riferimento
non inerziale la terra gira con una
velocità che in valore è costante ma che
group
essendo una velocità di rotazione la
direzione cambia continuamente quindi
einstein estende la teoria della
relatività ristretta anche ai sistemi di
riferimento non inerziali e ottiene la
teoria della relatività generale che un
altro modo di intendere la forza di
gravità
la legge di gravitazione universale di
newton più corretta in pratica quello
che einstein dice è che esiste lo spazio
tempo che è questo impalcatura
chiamiamola così anche se forse un po
improprio delle tre dimensioni spaziali
e di quella temporale e questo spazio
tempo può essere deformato dalla
presenza delle masse una cosa molto
difficile da immaginare visivamente per
il nostro cervello allora limitiamoci a
due dimensioni immaginiamo un telo
elastico come nella figura a se non ci
sono ma se pesi su questo telo elastico
quello semplicemente è piatto
se io ci metto un peso il telo elastico
si deforma come si vede in b e più
chiaramente in c che presenta la stessa
deformazione provvista di taglio quindi
che succede se io su questo telo
elastico vado a vado a lanciare una
biglia questa bibbia è costretta a
muoversi sul telo deformato che è curvo
e quindi comincerà a girare intorno al
peso questa è esattamente la stessa cosa
che avviene ad esempio tra la terra e il
sole il sole una grande massa dei forma
lo spazio tempo e lo spazio tempo e
curvo la terra è costretto a muoversi
sullo spazio tempo e gira intorno al
sole
questo modo di intendere la teoria della
gravitazione era più corretto per
descrivere una serie di anomalie che si
vedevano
il moto dei pianeti del sistema solare
però era un cambio di prospettiva così
straordinario che gli scienziati
volevano anche trovare delle prove più
concrete degli effetti che venissero
effettivamente predetti dalla teoria
della relatività generale
lei e ne venne in mente subito uno che
vi spiego con quest'immagine allora
quello che vedete lì in alto sulla
destra è un telescopio in realtà è un
satellite che vuole osservare quella
stellina luminosa che si trova invece
sulla sinistra al centro senza nessuna
lettera non dovrebbe essere in grado di
vederlo perché lungo il campo di vista
c'è una grossa galassia che succede però
la galassia e massa è in grado di
deformare lo spazio tempo e quindi i
raggi luminosi della sorgente girano
intorno alla galassia è ugualmente
arrivano al satellite che però non li
vede come se venissero da dietro la
galassia e ovviamente ma come se
venissero da due punti punti a eb in
cielo qui sotto vedete esattamente
quello che dovrebbe vedere il satellite
questo effetto si chiama effetto di
lente gravitazionale fu una delle prime
predizioni della teoria della relatività
gli scienziati si domandarono come fare
effettivamente a misurare questo effetto
e avevano la soluzione pronta perché nel
1919 ci sarebbe stata un eclissi di sole
che è quando sostanzialmente la luna
copre il disco solare di giorno quando
c'è un eclissi di sole ve lo dico per
esperienza diretta perché finalmente ho
visto un eclissi totale quest'anno in
cile si vedono le stelle che giorno
ora che succede o il sole che una massa
la luce del sole viene coperta vedo le
stelle
dovrei essere in grado di vedere una
serie di stelle intorno al disco solare
che dovrebbero essere coperte dal sole
ma riesco a vedere ugualmente per
effetto di lente gravitazionale parti
quindi una spedizione per andare nel
giorno all'africa del sud a vedere
queste classi la guida headington che
era un astronomo inglese e questo è
proprio una delle immagini che vennero
prodotte durante questo esperimento è
l'effetto che veniva previsto dalla
relatività generale venne effettivamente
osservato ed è interessante la reazione
di einstein
ovviamente la teoria della relatività
generale era una cosa così grande
era arrivata anche sui giornali
generalisti era su tutti quanti giornali
quindi intervistarono einstein per
chiedergli cosa che cosa farebbe se ed
in tono misurasse questo effetto che lei
ha previsto lui tranquillissimo rispose
mi spiacerebbe per lui
la teoria è comunque corretta
qualche anno dopo parlando di max planck
che quella sera quando dovevano arrivare
i risultati di questa misura era rimasto
sveglio per vedere se questo effetto
veniva effettivamente osservato disse se
avesse capito davvero la teoria della
relatività avrebbe fatto come me e
sarebbe andato a letto
noi non siamo abituati ad associare
l'intuizione alla scienza che molto
spesso consideriamo qualcosa di molto
quadrato se vogliamo in cui la
creatività non gioca alcun ruolo ma
invece non è vero
e qui einstein ci dimostra che la sua
lui credo fortemente nella sua
intuizione tra stata quella prima
intuizione che aveva avuto a 16 anni
lentamente a portarlo poi eleborare
completamente questa teoria che ripeto a
tantissime spettacolari conferme vi
faccio vedere anche una bellissima lente
gravitazionale qui a sinistra il pallino
luminoso che si vede al centro è una
galassia ellittica e l'anello è una
lente gravitazionale l'immagine
deformata di una galassia a spirale che
si trova dietro quella ellittica e
invece qui in basso e una schermata del
mio cellulare di qualche settimana fa
io ho un applicazione che mi avvisa ogni
volta che laico o virgo che un altro
rivelatore di onde gravitazionali che si
trova in italia a cascina vicino pisa
ogni volta che questi strumenti rilevano
un'onda gravitazionale a me arriva un
alert me ne arriva più o meno uno al
giorno e lo trovo veramente
straordinario perché fino a tre anni fa
noi di speravamo di riuscire a vedere le
onde gravitazionali
e adesso invece una semplice
applicazione mi dice in questo momento
la terra è stata attraversata da un'onda
gravitazionale e l'antenna le hanno
vista la dell'anno vista e come vi
dicevo tutto questo in qualche modo è
cominciato semplicemente dalla fantasia
di un bambino di 16 anni che era
appassionato di fisica grazie amici
[Applauso]